oh eric i got a new show for you because
you and i like the same
weird [ __ ] like nine day fiance have you
seen married at first sight
yeah dude it's this is this well you but
you just saw season one
you saw the original season oh yeah i
saw the original
one they got the new ones in new orleans
yeah but
it's so good i reject the premises
of all those type of shows that's why i
like hate watching them yeah
it's a [ __ ] show it's like the
bachelorette well hold on let's not
disrespect the best
right now that's the worst one that's
strike two eric okay
now you gotta strike two with me there's
no perspective they
they're disrespecting love
i mean it never works i think only like
one couple stayed together because it's
like
they take it actually looked it up
really
of all the shows there's ten couples
that are still together
and how many but how many seasons have
they done there's been you know between
a bachelor and bachelorette
and bachelor in paradise i don't know
it's been like
i guess they've been doing it 20 years
maybe oh 10 10
10 to get more than i thought yeah i
know the one couple because the one
homeboy played football at cu
i knew they were together had kids but
the bachelorette some [ __ ] the
bachelor's some [ __ ]
cause it's not real [ __ ] it's not real
they're living in this mansion
and then their dates are in helicopters
going to paris for the night
and then the show gets done and you're
in this one-bedroom apartment in
bourbon you're like damn that's why they
stay in the in the loop that's why they
do
bachelor's in paradise i mean they do
their paradise they keep doing it they
do the spin-offs and stuff
and i actually i actually love when
you know like the spin-off versions of
shows when it's just about to couple
and you're just like following this it's
like those the wrestling one
the two you don't know twins no no not
those it's
see there's so many of them it's a dude
and his wife oh miss
all right yeah your show is great
it's just a fun watch so you this has
been around for a minute yeah
you know you know what theo used to beat
his ass on uh the competitions oh really
beat his eyes real world no like the
real three rules strike three get out
i apologize she's new to podcasting
unbelievable so yeah so i like these
shows are
these these ones are weird so it's like
you get like even on 90 day fiance okay
let me tell you the [ __ ] show
is um the family chantelle
okay oh that's awful it's it's a
spin-off
there was this one couple that was on 90
day fiance
that girl's family is the most ignorant
yeah all right
ignorant [ __ ] i've ever seen
like a brother here's my problem here's
my problem i don't know if
they doing it for tv those two right
there yeah
yes it's her family because he's from
the dominican republic
or something you know what and even
they're so dumb
and let me say the word again ignorant
yeah
that i'm with him every time yeah you
side with him
with him and every single day i don't
know if you know she just got the new
titties too well new ones they live in
atlanta right
that's the couple i don't know yeah and
she just got
yo flat chest when the show first
started yeah
i thought i thought she would not like
that yo i remember one episode when she
went down there to meet his family and
uh
yes yes okay she thought they were no
but in the mom
thought that she was giving us these
chicken feet like we're dumb americans
yes just everything that comes out of
her mom's mouth
is i just go are you
like i gotta agree crazy this part of me
goes
either they're at home going like hook
everybody thinks we're dumb and we're
really making this money yeah i can
remember
they're just really dumb you're getting
too much credit they're getting so i
yeah and i you want to talk about hate
watching a show mm-hmm
this is the one that's happening one
i've been watching the bachelorette like
that you know i just yelled at home like
oh [ __ ] please
i only like the bachelorette when
they're going through the process when
they get actually start like
narrowing it down i'm out i like when
it's a [ __ ] show just like it's just
yeah
you need to watch this one because this
is she black
no they started with this white girl
who's been on the show before
so she's like she is the oldest
bachelorette she's 39. she's a good age
and she looks great though i'm married
at first i'm trying to be a just
you know but uh you know but to me
she's too old for these guys like
at first i thought she was too older
than not because of her age but just
because of like
they're too young bring her up what's
her name twenty-eight um
they got duke's 28 28 29 30 31 yeah
trying to get with this 39 year old
woman who's been through all this stuff
already he dated a 68 year old
should i leave i don't know
it's not looking strong for you now this
is the new girl
i like her okay but she replaces she's
not 39. no no listen
they were the 39 year old the 39 year
old said is love at first sight
okay and so they ended this they ended
her reign after three
episodes oh they're like all right no no
because she was like we're gonna get i'm
gonna get married to this one
well she was there for love the guy got
out of the car and she was like i think
i met my husband
oh so immediately i know that she's
bananas yeah okay you know you don't
even know if he loves his mom you don't
know anything about him you don't know
his favorite
you know nothing that feeling of like
love at first sight
that is that i i reject it it's not real
it's scary
it's yeah there's attraction at first
sight it might work out later
okay but it's the later means that you
went through a lot of stuff to make it
work out yeah but
this this chick she to me i i she made
me uncomfortable watching the show the
whole time because
she was so insecure and all this stuff
is like at 39 30.
bring up the 39 year old chinese
so what's her name i don't know what her
name was the bachelorette 39
years old i think her name is uh because
i i think i know you're talking about
but i don't want to miss
see they already gotten rid of her
they're not even showing her they took
her off
there she is right there at the bottom
yeah
claire crawley so she's like with this
dude dale
now oh they're together still there well
it's only been like a month yeah oh yeah
cause it was only three ever so yeah
like she looks great i got no no like
and everybody
the kind of dudes that should have been
on the show for her me
not the one no you're not the one you
would have broke her heart yeah you
would have broke her heart because in
five years when she's 44 you're gonna
wake up like nick cannon did and be like
why am i with my auntie
he looked
sleep she had cucumbers she had a wrap
on she was like
they actually cut you looked over like
they're like
you know and i'm sure my girl's gonna
wake up in two years i feel the same way
you know yeah but anyway the point is i
felt like she should have been with
someone that was more on her level
emotionally
yeah you know what i mean like i think
it should have been a dude who was like
you know 45 you know he pulls up in his
ferrari or he's like you know
old abandoned she does [ __ ] together
like she's a man somebody's got a [ __ ]
i was like what are you doing here now
my question is this okay
they got a new girl okay so it was a
white girl claire's white yeah and they
had a lot of black jews
you know everyone's down with this i
know he
hasn't dated a black woman at six years
god damn eric do you watch the show
he's a sugar mama now
see this is what i'm saying you know why
that happens just just real quick
like because like whatever the how old
your chick is
30 31 no that's not a sugar mama i'm
saying when you with these older women
that get when you're like young dudes
it's about trying to get to get back you
know yeah they couldn't get them i
wasn't yeah
well what do you mean they couldn't pull
that
so now they're like getting with these
like young dudes but it's not
to work yeah it's just not going to work
never it just doesn't for some reason
that dynamic doesn't work
different levels it's different level of
just emotionally mature whatever it is
i don't know who knows even if my i
can't believe i mean
whatever you just get back to my one
year yeah ahead so the girl she's white
and they got all these black dudes that
are going for her now they replaced her
with this like mixed black girl okay and
she like black dudes and my
question is i just wonder if like is
there a thought
for the guys that are there if they're
like oh
you know we weren't told oh yeah yeah i
just signed up for this no we were going
this way
they can't they can't but you can't no
yeah yeah one guy already left because
he he had feelings for claire uh he was
a white guy and he was like i still have
things for her and i
you know i came for this smart but i
don't believe he's like
oh i like the other chick the way
society is dude
yeah you you're probably sitting there
you like it's just like
it's just like the sketch show black
woman sketch show
have you seen it on uh ice meal on hbo
yep
i wasn't a huge fan of it okay maybe
delicate
it wasn't my favorite yeah you know i
know some of the people on the show
yeah i thought it was good but they got
a second season yeah and i bet you
the the pr department said you can't
cancel a show called
black lady sketch show yeah in 2019
and even if they wanted to cancel it end
of 2020 you can cancel that [ __ ] i
wanted to kids even if they were like
we don't like this this is terrible you
can't cancel a show like that
it's the same kind of feeling even if
you thought it was good or not i wasn't
a huge fan of it i
you know but there was some funny moment
whatever you know what i mean like if i
was an executive i probably would have
cancelled it for whatever reason
my own reasons right excuse me has
nothing to do with
race gender yeah i just didn't like it
yeah i didn't like i don't like a lot of
shows that are predominantly male
you know but it's not that's not the
reason why i don't like them i just
don't think it's funny
i can't believe you don't get down with
married at first sight i thought for
sure
i just haven't gotten to it yet dude the
new one in new orleans is because these
experts connect them i'm like what the
[ __ ] are they thinking
these experts some yeah like on this the
season when you're watching i'm like how
do they
like why did they think that the the new
one season i think it's 13 in new
orleans they connect this uh
this black guy who's like he he's he's
so animated
he he's so animated he's so happy yeah
they connect him with the same type of
girl
and it's like the best relationship
you've ever from the from the very
as soon as as soon as they see each
other it's like
boom really like god damn yeah that's
different so they're so they're so they
have some hit
that's what the team a little bit yeah
same i get i mean i think we should all
get together for that reason
an expert goes this is why you guys
match and this is your thing
yeah but like i remember watching steve
harvey's show one time and he had these
girls
shout out to her yeah speaking of cancer
they were looking for
love right yeah so he was trying to
prove a point so he had these guys come
on so there's like four guys four girls
and so they had the four girl
four guys and uh the girls picked the
one that they liked off
you know they saw him like oh i want him
and then he what he did after that is he
made the guys go behind a
a barrier and each woman had to talk to
them
and after they talked to them they
picked they all picked someone different
yup so it just shows that that's the
problem so
even if experts go this person is a
match for you
yeah if your site connected to your
brain is connected to your
libido yes yes looks at a person and is
like
but i want to have sex with that person
like that's what i'm
trying to think no matter what does that
happen on
the washington dc season because they
pick this dude who's he's a personal
trainer he's in shape and he's on these
like
you know i've dated a lot of girls i've
hooked up with a lot of girls we just
can't make a connection like cool that's
because all you're looking at the
physical part
we need to connect you with the
emotional part so they connect with dude
with a girl who's
you know she's whatever not great
real skinny
chin likes them if they look like a
crowbar but so
so right away like he's talking the
camera he's like it's just
like he's like strong and black yeah
yeah that too but skinny strong and
black yeah
yeah good uh yeah
but the dude is like in the confession
he's like it's just not my like that's
not what i'm attracted to the next words
like this is what you need
and the whole time it's a struggle and
he cheats on her and he's like this just
isn't my thing
and they're like you're a bad dude and
like everyone's shaming him i told my
guy go i go from a guy's perspective
perspective it's [ __ ] up because
off the bat there has to be physical
attraction otherwise
he's all probably set on forever like
it's just not gonna
it's never gonna be there well we need
to change the fact that you can
like when people fall in love online you
know or they talk about that
you're talking to someone for a while
you meet on a dating app or whatever and
you talk to this person without you
haven't met them yet
the problem is our brain fills in the
gap of all the things that we want
yes so we attach ourselves to this one
thing we like about the person
and we fill in the gap with everything
else of all our fantasy
yeah yeah you know and then you actually
get to know the person
and then you realize oh i don't this
there's so much i really don't like
because it's isn't it strange that how
physical attraction can go away like
this
once somebody opens their mouth from one
man 100 come on bro like like
that's why i start dealing with young
girls yes i get that
that's your
but i'm talking about i'm talking about
it completely goes away
like you look at this person and you
just go yuck
but that whatever that so that tells me
that that's
worthless if you can throw away physical
attraction
like it happens like this then that
means how important is it
but well sometimes though you meet
someone who you're physically attracted
to and then they do check the boxes and
they're dope even
emotionally so then you got wifey i know
but that's what we're saying
yeah but i think i think that that's the
that that's but you're i think you're
missing out on
um actually finding a connection with
someone that
when you have that other connection that
that physical thing
can happen it can happen agree it does
happen oh yeah you know it's like it's
it's weird that like men feel like it
doesn't happen
because women they just look to me i
feel like women look for different
things
that make them physically attracted to
someone you'll see ugly dudes if you've
got chicks all
the time
bingo but when you ask when you when i
when you hear the things that they're
attracted to i'm just like okay
it's not the same way it's not the same
thing where that we're attracted but
we're built like that that's in our dna
i don't know man i but i but i think
that like i think that we're we
are detached from our
emotional and physical we're detached
from it we don't necessarily combine
them they're they're mute they're not
mutually exclusive
well social media is making it worse
though far as because because so many
relationships happen on dating apps and
social media oh wow so
you're just seeing a person with their
physical appearance you don't know [ __ ]
about them
or they're posting their 15-second
at least
yeah you're like oh i like to travel oh
yeah you're filling in the gaps
you know that's why like that's why you
know i think i've even said this before
even on this show it's like you know
you know what goes with if you hear a
dude say oh this is the best [ __ ] i've
ever had
i've ever had i've ever had yeah you got
you you've all said that but you've had
an experience you're like oh
but you know what you never hear with
that and we've been together five years
oh yeah that's true that's true because
you know what's synonymous with best
[ __ ] ever yeah crazy new [ __ ]
yeah that's fair too you can't be new it
can't be i think
it's just and i think we're all like
that so we have this like experience
and we have this like you know because
we've like again we've filled in the
gaps of all the other things that we
don't know yet
but i'm telling you i think that if we
would give ourselves the opportunity
to change the reason why we're attracted
to people
uh sexually attracted to people if we
change that reason i think we'd be way
happier but you're talking about messing
with dna
inside males i don't i don't think it's
a thing where you say it's a
testosterone yeah i i
you know it's just like we're just wired
like that like the same like well
to your defense like monogamy's not
natural for for dudes
i don't think it's natural for anyone
not just dudes i mean
don't don't act like it's just men out
here cheating talk that talk yeah cause
i've been cheated on speak youtube
it's a long story he was rising up yeah
everyone cheats everyone thinks that
they don't have enough and it's just
like
you know it's because when you're young
listen here's my problem with
the world okay like like we
we qualify ourselves by these things
like if somebody says to you listen
we're all human beings right
yeah but it's like okay is that how
we're all related
like that's not enough in the same way
that you can't just say
men you know like we're all different
you know but
they put us in a box so there you go so
same thing with women
they're all different like different
things happen at different
age groups you know so it's like i
always say it's crazy how
uh women in their you know when they get
to their mid to late 30s
how woke they get yeah you know you know
it's like all of a sudden they're
looking at hey don't put your
don't be naked on the internet yeah yeah
you know don't don't
respect yourself yeah it's like oh you
mean because your options are limited
now yes
you know uh so now you want to tell
these to these other girls
these other women man like you know what
i'm tired of have you been on instagram
you go to reels all right reels
real little videos it's our video has
taken over
they're trying they're taking over yeah
they tried to buy tick-tock or whatever
and tick-tock was like no
instagram does what they always do well
we'll just do our own [ __ ] yeah oh [ __ ]
you go on reels man it's all young
women dancing in bikinis and being sexy
mm-hmm every single like you can slide
like this
yeah and they can't dance either right
no because i don't got you know the
right ass and
you know and you just titties and i go
who's this for like i'm talking about
endless and so my problem is like
because i've looked at it so often now
that's all i get because i tell other
people they go well all mine is cat
videos you know it's your algorithm yeah
whatever the algorithm is is for me
it's like it's all these like you know
and i'm like what the hell
like who's this so what i'm saying
though is like i get it these are
they're 18 to 24 25.
they love their body they love being
sexy they love the attention yeah
i'm not gonna shame them for the [ __ ]
okay you want to do that that's that's
it
but they're different from people who
are like oh now my body don't look the
same as that
i don't want to be on the internet like
that or like whoopi goldberg in them
that were
were getting on that young actress who
her phone got hacked
and her nudes leaked and they were like
well that's why you shouldn't do that no
no [ __ ] that's why you shouldn't do
that yeah yeah yeah
okay but like if you're 20 your body is
banging and you're like i want to share
i'm like okay do you
it comes with some negativity it's going
to come with some
energy stuff yeah yeah it's going to be
it's like i always say it's like a
casino
and this is how i feel about like sex
work okay
right sex work is like a casino there's
a bad element around it
yes it's fun yes people are making a
living yes there's a lot of money in it
but around a casino there's crime
and there's like you know what i mean
that's something yeah there's a darkness
there's a darkness there's a dark
sketchiness that goes around it that's
the same thing with sex work too
you know there's some sketchy some
darkness that goes around it so well
that's what i'm saying about these
things but i just go
like what what you know people are at
different
stages in their life and we have to
start to acknowledge that it's just like
when they get on like
you know i hate this term well male
comedians are acting it's like
yeah yeah yo yo ain't all of us no
yeah that's not fair it's not fair yeah
but you put the word male
and all of a sudden it's like that now
we're all in the same boat yeah we're
not all in the same boat chill out with
that [ __ ]